and good afternoon thank you so much for
joining us at four o'clock i'm kirsten
joyce
and i'm christian casa as we continue to
track some breaking news this afternoon
two-year-old amari nicholson's body was
found earlier today
near the emerald suites at paradise and
twain one week after he was reported
missing
8 news now victoria sahi is live where
the discovery
was made victoria
just behind me here at segal suites is
where i saw mari's body being taken away
it's within walking distance of the
emerald suites where he was reported
missing
it appears his body was left behind this
wall right here
the scene at segal suites was blocked
off but many people living in the area
watched as they say they have been
following the disappearance of amari
ever since it happened there were many
tears shed by complete strangers
as amari's body was being loaded up we
kept hearing them say
i love you amari one woman i talked to
had just been at the wash up at
cambridge recreation center where they
were doing a search for omari
as soon as she heard he was recovered
she rushed to this area at segal suites
because she says
she didn't want amari to be alone
he's just a baby he was alone and you
know
all these people came out because we
care about him and even though we
weren't we didn't know him and we
weren't close to him
you know he's still always going to hold
a special place in our heart
several others who lived in the building
also seemed very shocked
tons of motions here today but i also
want to add as the scene here was
clearing up as a crowd gathered at the
mcdonald's next door where
taylor nicholson and mary's mom seem to
be
talked to by police again a crowd
gathered there they were
screaming and yelling that she should be
arrested too but nicholson seemed to not
show
any emotions reporting live at emeril
suites victoria saha 8 news now